my name is Salem like the cat she know
about the cat my pronouns are he/him
and I work at Etsy if you don't know
Etsy they're a marketplace for handmade
and vintage stuff and we're hiring so if
you want to hire you know come find me
there's like a whole contingency of Etsy
people here as well this is my very
first conference talk as well so if you
have any feedback for me please do not
withhold it I would love to hear about
it so okay cool um so I wanted to talk
about how we migrated from an in-house
written build system webpack yes and
specifically I want to talk about why it
took us so long to do that so a little
bit of detail about what I do and I work
at a team at Etsy called a web platform
team if you've ever worked at a place
that has a front-end infrastructure team
it's probably very similar our whole job
is to manage how HC writes and builds
stuffs like CSS and more relevantly
JavaScript it's probably why you're all
here to hear about the JavaScript part
this talk is essentially about how we
moved from one build system to another
but this doesn't mean that I'm going to
talk about how to write a config file or
how to get brand-new es6 code and really
old internet explorer my goal here is to
talk about the weird problems that we
enter and how we fixed them and where
all my heroine so this talk this talk is
like about five parts I'm gonna first
tell you a little bit about Etsy and our
old build system that we called bilder
I'm gonna talk about why we picked web
pack I'm gonna talk about some of the
development headaches that we had some
of the production headaches we had and
then this really weird bug that we
experienced while rolling it out in
which four milliseconds delayed our
launch by about three months so that's a
gonna be a fun one so it's beginning
parts are boring at least stay to the
end so before I get into it there are
two big old caveats that are worth
mentioning number one the decisions that
we made were true for us at the time
that you made them there may now be
better alternatives because JavaScript
changes really quickly but they either
weren't around for us weren't
battle-tested enough for us to use them
javascript as you all probably know
changes very quickly which is the whole
reason that we wanted a really flexible
build system in the first
and number two all of the things that
I'm going to talk about today we're big
team efforts I know a whole lot about
how I'd seize friend and infrastructure
works but I'm speaking on be on behalf
of my whole team I think my voice kinda
disappeared but I'm speaking on behalf
of my team that collectively built and
researched all the things that I'm going
to talk about today they they kick ass
and I really really love working I think
Joe is right up there somewhere in front
that's my teammate Joe there's also John
and Natalia not here right now but they
like they're just wonderful people to
work with alright enough of that I'm
gonna get started with the actual talk
part I'd like to talk a bit about Etsy's
codebase and it's these old build system
it's hard to tell you about a migration
process without giving you a little bit
of context so here it is this is that
C's codebase it's a lot like any other
codebase at a medium-sized company it
was once small and weird but then it
stayed weird but it got really big
something scaled really well and some
things did not live code lives in one
big mono repo that is to say that the
code that makes XE show up in your web
browser from our API all the way down to
our CSS lives in one route or e we call
our mono repo Etsy web people have you
know different opinions about mono repos
but it's worked surprisingly well for us
it has helped us facilitate learning and
it's made finding examples and reusing
patterns really really simple however
one thing to not scale very well as he
grew was as a JavaScript part of our
code base and more specifically our
JavaScript build system that's a
compactor so this system is something
that we named build up and we named
because it built a lot of it was written
in-house more than eight years ago and
it existed in various incarnations for
all intents and purposes it did its job
really well for a really long time for
those of you who may not be familiar
with JavaScript build systems a build
system is something that just takes our
files resolves their dependencies
bundles them together makes them as if
in a small efficient and as small as
possible and makes them Bunch we're
gonna
this can you hear me okay cool cool just
want to make sure y'all still there -
its to make make make sure that all our
bundles work in different locales and
browsers all over the world this was
that our JavaScript was particularly
sophisticated when build a pack was
first written we gotta hit play on this
part it's gonna be like a carnival game
where I have to aim on a screen one more
time hey there it goes okay so when
building was first written Etsy wasn't
this really sleek interactive homepage
that you can see here complete with
image carousels overlays cool animations
and a responsive navigation bar and a
real cool branding looked more like that
javascript was just decoration on top of
a really highly server driven experience
having one file depend on another was
pretty infrequent and when that did
happen it was usually for large globally
scoped libraries like jQuery for a long
time our code didn't take a lot of work
to turn into a production-ready asset
few dependencies needed to be resolved
and nothing needed to be transpiled
production builds took very little time
and I see this is pretty important we
deploy code dozens of times in a single
day and slowing down a deployment is
something that we would try to avoid at
all costs so developing javascript was
similarly pretty simple that's supposed
to be me if we load a page in
development that requests some
JavaScript that javascript file would be
built from our source and sent back
inside of one request to keep track of
all the possible files that we might
need to request it kept a list of all of
them which we brilliantly called the
build list when we served a file would
make sure that it was in that list
somewhere the build list was used in
production then later to determine the
entirety of what we needed to build when
we deployed it in development if a file
was if the requested file was not in the
bill bust would respond with some
JavaScript that throws an exception
telling you to add your file to that
list this ensured that we could
essentially build any file we wanted on
demand while making sure that we knew
the extent of what we needed to build by
the time we were ready to go to
production we used required ojs to
manage and resolve our dependencies
maybe you haven't even heard of this
because it's a relatively old library
but we still have been
using it and pretty simple up and until
we move to impact it is we first start
by sending a copy of requires a yes to
your web browser and then we follow it
down with some of our own code required
je s then allows our own code to then
use style module definitions as you can
see here for some of you this might
sound like it's out of it for us it was
pretty cutting-edge at the time that we
did this and D stands for asynchronous
module definition which is just syntax
for defining modules and their
dependencies we define an array of
imports which require then resolves for
us those imports then get passed to a
callback as arguments and all of our
code go body of one of these callback
where it has access to all of the
imports ja builders job was to make sure
that all of the necessary modules needed
on the page were bundled into one
javascript file so that required jeaious
had access to everything it needed in
the browser at some point react came
along for those of you who are
unfamiliar react is just a library that
makes writing large client-side
applications a lot easier sometime
around 2016 we decided that it would be
a really good fit for some of our seller
tools when we decided to introduce
reacts to our code base everyone was
excited react however strongly relies on
sx a syntax that looks like HTML
controversially inlined into javascript
if you want to be able to use the syntax
we need to make a build system that can
do more than just glue files together it
also had to be able to convert JSX back
into regular old javascript so we used
an old version of it and we non-trivial
e bolted it on to builder so it's a
stapler this allowed us to train reacts
I added those staples like last night it
was like gosh
this allowed us to turn reacts custom
JSX
since to into plain old JavaScript there
was one problem with this setup however
cuz we built every file only when it was
requested rather than whenever some part
of it was edited we had no way of
knowing if Ed had changed or not since
the last time it was requested so we had
to rebuild every asset every time we
wanted to use it
transpiling JSX into javascript it
worked
instead so a spied on reacts heavily
ended up taking a good bit longer to get
served
but JSX was new and it wasn't you he
places yet so very few people felt the
pain of long whoops and rebuild tons in
development besides bad could've get you
know it's just javis right we know
didn't last very long
all of these quirks together meant that
loading something large like a single
page app implied rebuilding the entire
thing from scratch every time the page
reloaded plus our code base was only
getting bigger
the last hunt we had over a thousand
separate JavaScript assets to output
making up of over 11,000 separate
individual modules react code was used
in a lot more places and I started to
take the better part of a minute to show
up on the page in development which made
it ur ating very very tedious on top of
this developers were starting to ask for
the ability to use es6 in tax and
features felt like a non-starter for us
react support was difficult to implement
so it worked
it certainly wasn't sustainable
repeating the process with es6 felt like
a non-starter we knew we needed to do
something this is where i've told myself
that I'm going to drink water and you
are all going to take 15 seconds and
introduce yourself to the people who are
right next to you so that you don't hear
me gulping over the microphone okay cool
so I drank my water and it is now time
for me to talk about the solution to
every one of our problems people started
talking around this time about this
brand-new open-source build system it
was called web pack you might have heard
of it these are these are all the gifts
for my entire presentation they're just
right here all right any new developer
that we hired asked if they could use
webpack and the internet made it sound
like every tech company that used
javascript also use webpack while it's
always healthy to be skeptical of things
that it sounds like
every tech company is using webpack did
sound kind of interesting it sounded a
lot like bilder and that it built stuff
but it also sounded very different and
that I had a robust development
experience it was highly extensible and
it had a bunch of built-in performance
optimizations for our code most of all
it was supposed to be very fast
especially for development so we did a
little bit of research oh I just wanted
to point out this is a fast chicken it's
a recurring motif so keep it in mind
so we did a little bit of research we
evaluated a bunch of alternatives and we
decided that going down the path of
building our JavaScript with webpack
instead of build a what's the right path
our goal was to create a new system that
inevitably would act a lot like builder
we had two requirements for any new
system that we want to adopt number one
it would have to be able to take care of
development builds without too much
interaction from developers one of the
nicest things about builder was that
despite its slow build speeds you could
navigate around the entire site in
development without worrying about how
the build system worked and the other
requirement was I don't have to build
our production code in about five
minutes as I mentioned before I'd see
deploys code to production dozens of
times in a day which is a core part of
how we work if our builds took longer
than five minutes I'd see this with
deployments would slow down which is not
a good thing for us so webpack what was
cool about web pack for us well it's
highly configurable instead of a build
list a web pack uses a configuration
file usually called something like web
pack dog config it is in the same file
that you specify every aspect of web
packs behavior from how you'd like to
support templates if any to what sort of
performance optimizations you'd like to
make there's oftentimes means really
large really scary config files which
isn't always the right idea for small
projects but for a large code base with
weird quirks everywhere having something
that could adapt in a fit to our code
was very invaluable
we spent a while writing out a really
nice web pack dog config file and we
also spent a lot of time writing very
good plugins and loaders to emulate
different different features that build
our currently supported which at the
time included everything from
transpiling
templates to enlightening SVG's after
spending after spending hours sending
things up just right we finally got Webb
back
build our whole goodness but it wasn't
quite what we expected it took about a
half hour to do it ate up 20 gigs of our
service memory and maxed out every
single one of its courts this this is a
this is a real screen shot and it had
the unclear progress indicator that
everyone has come to know and love this
made it exceptionally hard to figure out
why it was so slow so we definitely had
a lot to learn about improving web packs
performance but at the end of the day we
needed to change a lot about how our
codebase looked and about how web based
web pack worked with it if we wanted to
use it with Etsy with its on-demand
development bills and its five-minute
production deployments ok I'm bring to
drinking water again so tell the person
next to you what your text editor of
choice is without trying to convince
them that yours is the right one I hope
I hope the answer was vim but it's ok if
it wasn't ok our first order of business
was to get a development workflow that
was good
if engineers could develop with web pack
and validate that their code still
worked with bilder in production we
could at least improve their development
times or we figured out how to get web
pack to work in production we wouldn't
be able to offer new features like es6
yet since build up during the production
builds didn't know anything about es6
transpilation
but maybe we could make the engineers
that had to use react on a daily basis
have a good time doing it so why does
web pack take so long to build and that
was the first thing we needed to figure
out when web pack first starts it does a
complete build of all of your code first
and then it enters watch mode where it
monitors your source files for changes
and then it kicks off a partial rebuild
every time it sees one
this pattern allows development to be
extremely fast relative to complete
rebuilds we figured that the longer
initial build coupled with rebuilds of a
second or two would probably be much
better but if that initial build took a
half hour and ate up all of our memory a
two-second rebuild probably wouldn't
matter all that much on top of that our
codebase was really big and it was only
getting bigger so whatever a solution we
came up with would have to scale why is
it necessary to do a complete build of
all of our code first you ask well web
pack makes inferences about
your code in the context of your whole
project for example it is smart enough
to group commonly requested modules
together so that they can be cached
efficiently between pages it can only
make these optimizations if it
understands your entire project not just
your individual files this is good if
your project is nicely scoped but it
makes a lot less sense in a mono repo
where everything from our internal tools
to our home page code all live so we
started by trying to make web pack
faster and less resources intensive in
general something that's really hard to
do both of at the same time we got a lot
of mileage from caching plugins like
cache loader and hard source and
allowing web pack to process our modules
in parallel using plugins like happy
pack was certainly a good idea but at
the end of the day we still had a
prohibitively heavy first build time I
can't believe I found this image it's
amazing we also looked at web pack
development server for potential
solutions the development server by
design and chooses to keep everything in
memory including its finished output
files for us this meant that our whole
codebase plus all the transpilation
information about our whole codebase
plus all of our built files from our
whole codebase all had the fit memory if
you remember we have a very large code
base there also unfortunately isn't a
way to turn this behavior off without
modifying the developers source
development service source code which is
actually really like a really nicely
written repository and if you're ever
interested in how this sort of things
work I would totally recommend reading
through the source even if there was a
way to turn this behavior off it wasn't
clear that it would save us from
ourselves
and from the size of our mono repo over
time all of this put together made it
sound like it was a probably a good idea
to keep web pack from building the
entire code base all at once one really
easy solution was just to make a bunch
of different config files for different
areas of the codebase and only build the
one that was being used at the time we
can make each region be small enough so
that memory it is reasonable and the
initial build times are closer to one
minute rather than 11 for us this meant
that splitting our codebase into 11
regions was the right number
we had a region for things like our
seller tools the core buyer experience
and our internal tools this would have
worked but we wanted to emulate want to
build those nicer features quietly
building files without any additional
interaction from the developer juggling
a bunch of configurations just to browse
around Etsy on your work machine was not
ideal
that we probably needed to write
something of our own so we wrote a thing
called Kevin Kevin is a plugin for the
Express webserver framework and it's
only job is to manage a bunch of web
pack instances why did we name it Kevin
look how funny he is when a request for
any file comes in Kevin determines which
web pack config is responsible for
building that file if any and then it
starts a web pack instance for that
config once the compiler is finished it
starts running that code in watch mode
rebuilding files as they're edited much
like web packs development server if
Kevin gets a request for another file in
a different config it does the same
thing if there are ever too many
compilers running Kevin will shut down
that compiler based on a free cincy
algorithm which is frequency and recency
this keeps us from building the whole
codebase and it has the added benefit of
making sure that the code base has has
regions of it that are all related to
each other rather than grouped into one
massive blob the only extra thing to
consider is that really long first build
if we requested if we request for a
JavaScript file times out after 30
seconds and starting up a web pack
server takes closer to a minute we're
gonna end up timing out in development
for what seems to be no reason so kid in
time out that's the that's the joke
our solution was to just serve some
static JavaScript that shows an overlay
of what's being built if we just started
up an instance of web pack it is modeled
after the Domino's Pizza Tracker we also
exposed some data about the status of
every active compiler so that the
overlay is able to monitor the status of
its build and reload the page whenever
it's done the end result is a fully
automatic process that keeps memory
usage low and keep engineers informed
about the state of all of their builds
without requiring them to manage a build
system with any luck Kevin will be
available as open source software very
soon all right another water break in 15
seconds or less tell a neighbor what you
did for adventure day let me really
quickly talk about production Eisinger
code and then that juicy bug that I've
been waiting for ok I want to talk about
production izing our code but more
specifically I want to talk about
localization since there's a lot of
other much less interesting things that
winning that went into getting our code
production
ready so at this point on our webpack
journey development was working we even
started to onboard a handful of
developers so that they could start
giving us feedback most of which was
pretty good because they could build all
of their code much faster we saw because
we weren't building production code with
build a pack yet we were not quite ready
to enable es6 support but the benefits
of web pack brought to the development
speed or wins in and of themselves our
next order of business was to get
production have that same speed there is
that chicken again reminding us that we
need to get 5-minute production bills
that is our goal a working development
environment meant that we were at least
able to successfully build our own code
but we need to productionize it this
involved minifying it but more
critically it meant localizing all of
our assets into eleven different
languages localization is a little
tricky with webpack the general
assumption is that for every locale that
you want to support you need to kick off
a separate web pack build web packs
localization plugin uses a file that
contains localized strings that you
provide and your code uses a function to
get access to those strings it seems
simple enough
using this method constant strings can
be defined in one file and swapped out
between builds without your JavaScript
changing there is an implication here
that's a little tricky web pack ends up
with a different configuration for each
locale that you support because the
plugin needs to be configured
differently for each language this meant
that in order to build 11 languages you
need to run 11 different web pack built
for Etsy one of our beefy primary
deployment servers again 32 gigs of ram
64 32 cores 64 gigs of ram it's big it's
really big
it could take as long as five or six
minutes for one build we could maybe run
two in parallel and have the resources
and get like eight or nine minutes for
those two builds but that would still
mean that all of our builds take
something like an hour we were also
constrained by the fact that we were
actively moving SC from hardware in our
own data centers to the cloud well this
is well this was happening we couldn't
just ask for a new hardware let alone a
dozen or so of the most powerful
computers that we used to have if we
were trying to keep pace with bilder
which could get our code ready in
something like five minutes we were
going to have to cheat a little bit
luckily for us cheating is okay because
builder cheats too let me explain what I
mean here when it needs to localize a
bunch of code into eleven different
languages builder doesn't build that
code eleven different times
instead it inserts placeholder strings
around the places where the translations
will eventually need to go later when
that build is mostly done and it looks
like word salad
it goes back through each file finds
those placeholders and swaps them out
for actual localized strings in every
language if you speak French you will
know that this is an accurate
translation compared with web packs
apparently deprecated
internationalization plugin this seemed
like a much faster approach I actually
didn't know that this was deprecated at
the time that I wrote this talk um so
you know like I said JavaScript changes
very quickly anyways we tweaked our
plugins that were responsible for
providing translated strings and had
them insert placeholders instead once
the build was finished we'd be left with
a bunch of production-ready files with a
bunch of placeholders in them from there
a plugin that we wrote would iterate
through our assets and do a find and
replace writing a copy of the source to
disk with new locales inlined
this is actually a lot easier than it
sounds this whole screenshot is
essentially all of the code but here are
the juicy bits we're able to just take
our source code and call dot split on it
with our placeholder when the resulting
array would contain original source code
in the even indexes and the strings that
needed translating in the odd indexes
would iterate through the odd indexes
and translate them in case you're
curious we get our translations from a
separate service that we maintain which
just dumps static translation files onto
all of our servers this message was
actually so fast that we were able to
provide localization in development this
is why Kevin is has Italian on his
forehead we could do this quick enough
by translating things as they were
requested rather than building every
file into every language possible thanks
to this method we were able to get our
production bills ready in well under 5
minutes ok very last section I will go
through it quickly in 15 seconds or less
tell your neighbor if you can speak more
than one language for the last part of
this talk let me tell you about that 4
milliseconds that kept us from building
this whole thing 3 months earlier than
we actually did so we were finally at
the point where we felt ready to try web
pack built code on production traffic
very exciting development was looking
good production was building quickly and
a bunch of our end-to-end tests showed
that things were still the same
however build systems are very hard to
replace a new build system has to work
in every language for every
on the site like we talked about but it
also has to work in every single browser
no matter how old or how cutting-edge it
may be if our page doesn't work people
will stop using our site and we may lose
money so what we do when we want to gain
confidence in a huge change we run an
a/b test this is NAB test it's a stock
photo of an a/b test we actually ran
five separate ones and they all looked
pretty good you can see all of the
important metrics that we track say no
change next to them which is actually as
good as we could have hoped and yet in
spite of all this we had some pretty
alarming changes in every one of our
browser performance metrics every page
was running way slower than we expected
some of our pages were up to 14% slower
which is unheard of it's an agenda in
the general rule if your site's
performance get worse so it is your
site's money so people were very scared
about this change we had to figure out
what was going wrong before we could
launch but before we could launch
webpack before I go on let me talk about
our client-side metrics really quickly
many of you will probably know this sort
of thing but some of you may not and I
hope that this is a good refresher and
let's see we track a lot of things but
two things in particular when we're
looking at client-side performance one
is Dom content loaded and one is page
load so when the browser parses our HTML
it goes through line by line and
evaluates everything one line at a time
for most resources like this stylesheet
it downloads and executes the whole
thing before continuing the parts of the
page some things like this image tag
will kick off a request but will not
block the browser from continuing to
parse the page here is our JavaScript at
the very bottom like CSS JavaScript is
downloaded and executed before the
browser can continue some JavaScript
code like a network request or a timeout
calls do not block the browser and are
added to a list of tasks that the
browser can take care of at a later time
finally when the browser finishes
parsing all of our HTML it fires the Dom
content loaded event which says that the
structure of the page is complete even
if we're still waiting for that image
there it is once all of our sub
resources load that is a thing that you
can buy on etsy.com
once all of our sub resources load like
that image and when the browser has run
out of tasks to immediately take care of
it says that the page is done and fires
the page load event to recap Dom content
loaded fires when the pages structure is
in place and
load fires when everything else is
loaded and no scripts are waiting to be
executed both of these were slower for
us this raised two questions one what is
so small yet so different that we missed
it and two if something is so different
why do people still buy things on
etsy.com
so we started by investing investigating
our performance monitoring code and we
double check that we weren't shipping
any extra code to our clients but both
of these things turned up nothing so we
decided to investigate how our code was
running in the browser this is a flame
graph for our listing page which is the
paid that the page that shows an item
for sale on Etsy the graph shows our
code built with builder here the
horizontal axis represents time and the
vertical axis represents layers of
execution every rectangle represents a
function call or a piece of execution
and everything below that rectangle is a
sub task related to it this particular
slice of the graph shows what the
browser does when it parses the main
javascript file on this page seems
pretty quiet takes about 18 seconds now
what does web packs look like it looks a
lot worse this is the same file as the
previous graph but it's taking four
times as long for kicks here they are
side by side clearly builder is doing a
lot less so this is kind of concerning
so why is this happening even if our
conversion numbers look good this big
difference may mean that we're missing a
performance win let's take another look
at the whole flame graph built with
builder this is roughly the area that we
were looking at before this is where Dom
content loaded fires this here is page
load and this is apparently where our
JavaScript file was actually getting
executed so zooming in a little bit that
rectangle right there it's the main body
of our JavaScript file which for some
reason is getting executed much later
than we thought so it seems like
builders code is running well after the
page load event has fired which doesn't
seem to happen with the web pack code in
other words our performance metrics
we're not accounting for the time it
took to actually run our JavaScript but
rather when the built code with excuse
me when that JavaScript was built with
builder code built with web pack did not
have this problem so we know why people
were still buying stuff the same things
have happened but our measurements have
moved we still when you need to know why
this was happening
so let's look back at our two metrics
specifically let's look at load and very
specifically let's look at that part
that says that there are no outstanding
scripts waiting to be executed what if
something was telling our scripts to
wait a second
before running tricking the browser into
thinking that the page is ready very
quickly because I know I'm like very
overtime let's dig into the meat of
required genius as a reminder requires a
library that builder was built around
we sent a copy of it to our browsers
where it's responsible for starting up
our code and managing our codes
dependencies here is where requirejs
kicks off our execution and it's wrapped
in this next tick function what does
that do if we dig a little bit further
it looks like it's just a four
millisecond set timeout call this would
tell that our out this would tell our
browser that our code can be executed
four milliseconds into the future this
isn't a hard and fast time and the
browser is totally allowed to push
things back a little bit later if it
needs in other words requires a yes
tells the browser that none of our code
needs to run right away require jeaious
may do this because it gives the browser
a second to finish loading the page
before starting any JavaScript and also
might do this because set timeout was a
really popular way to make you
performance numbers look good in 2010
it's hard to know for sure but we know
that web pack does not do this so it's a
lot more trustworthy so knowing that
this was the bug what did we do we did
not wrap all of our code and set timeout
calls that would just make our numbers
look better but it wouldn't tell us
anything that we needed to know but we
did add some new metrics to help
validate that web pack code was in that
slew we added a timer to every one of
our top 5 pages here yellow is webpack
and lower is better those timers were
supposed to measure how long it took for
all of our JavaScript to run on those
pages we were very happy with this graph
ok I'm about done in conclusion it took
us almost a year and a half to move the
web back that is a very long time and
it's a lot of hair pulling we really
hope that they would be the Silver
Bullet that would solve all of our
problems out of the box but at the end
of the day we had a lot to learn about
build systems performance and our own
codebase regardless of what we migrated
to I felt like there should be a three
point slide thing so but there are so
many winnings that we had that it's kind
of hard to pick just three but I tried
anyways number one your codebase gets
bigger not smaller if you're trying to
find small performance wins to get your
build time under some threshold it
probably won't last very long a solution
that anticipates your problem going
twice in size will always win out number
two always question what other companies
websites articles and blogs claim to be
best practices what works well for one
person may not always work well
if we accepted that web packs
internationalization plugin was our only
option we still be waiting an hour for
our JavaScript to build and finally if
you can afford to take extra time on a
big risky project
you absolutely should one of the nicer
parts about our migration that was that
no one was critically stuck on our work
we really hated that that metrics bug
cost us months of time when we were so
close to being done but we ended up
learning so much more about performance
the browser and our code and at the end
of the day after almost a year and a
half of wild problems and pulling my own
hair out web pack is still pretty great
software so that is my talk if you have
any questions please hit me up on
slacker on Twitter if you like this
stuff my team is hiring and of course
thank you all so very much
[Applause]
[Music]